(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
APPS ARE THOSE THINGS ON YOUR
PHONE THAT YOU USE WHILE YOU
IGNORE THE PERSON YOU'RE HAVING
A CONVERSATION WITH.
WE FOUND A FEW REALLY GREAT
RIDICULOUS APPS THAT ACTUALLY
EXIST.
SO I'M GOING TO NAME TWO
POSSIBLE APPS AND FOR 250
POINTS, YOU TELL ME WHICH ONE IS
REAL.
HERE'S THE FIRST ONE, AIRPNP, AN
APP THAT CONNECTS YOU TO PEOPLE
WHO WILL ALLOW YOU TO USE THEIR
TOILET.
OR P4-ME, AN APP THAT CONNECTS
YOU TO PEOPLE WHO WILL WATCH YOU
USE YOUR TOILET.
PAUL SCHEER.
>> P4-ME HAS TO BE AN APP.
>> Chris: WELL, I THINK THE
CORRECT ANSWER IS ACTUALLY
AIRPNP.
>> WHAT?!
>> Chris: YEAH.
YOU COULD JUST USE SOMEONE'S
BATHROOM IF YOU'RE ON THE GO.
>> THAT IS REALLY POLITE AND
NICE AND NOT CREEPY AT ALL.
>> Chris: YEAH, I KNOW.
>> I THOUGHT THE INTERNET
WOULD BE WAY MORE CREEPY.
>> Chris: WELL, THEY ARE GOING
TO FILM YOU WHILE YOU ARE DOING
IT.
YOU ARE NOT DOING IT IN YOUR
TOILET.
>> THAT MAKES A DIFFERENCE.
>> IS THIS FROM THE SAME PEOPLE
WHO BROUGHT YOU "DUKE AND
BOUNCE"?
(LAUGHTER)
>> WHAT WE'RE LEARNING FROM THIS
MAP IS THAT THERE ARE 288 PLACES
TO DO THIS IN GERMANY.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: DEFINITELY.
>> (imitating German accent):
HOW CAN I GET SOME STRANGERS
INTO MY HOUSE TO PEE HERE?
THERE MUST BE A WAY.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: I LOVE YOUR
GERMAN ACCENT.
NOW I WANT YOU TO OPEN THE ARC
OF THE COVENANT AND YOUR FACE
JUST MELT.
>> IT'S BEAUTIFUL, BEAUTIFUL!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: PAUL AND BRANDON, KEEP
YOUR EYES SHUT.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE, MAGIC BUTT
INTERACTIVE ASS, AN INTERACTIVE
IMAGE OF A WOMAN'S ASS THAT
JIGGLES AND REACTS TO PINCHING
AND SLAPPING.
OR ENCOURAGE-A-BONER, A VIRTUAL
FLACCID PENIS THAT GETS ERECT
WHEN YOU SHAKE YOUR PHONE.
(LAUGHTER)
I'D LIKE TO REMIND ALL OF
AMERICA THAT ONE OF THESE THINGS
IS REAL.
ANDY DALY.
>> I AM VERY EXCITED ABOUT
ENCOURAGE-A-BONER.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: WELL, LET'S FIND OUT.
LET'S FIND OUT.
OH, IT'S MAGIC BUTT.
(LAUGHTER)
I THINK THIS ALSO JUST
ENCOURAGED A BONER.
I THINK IT IS BOTH.
I THINK IT'S BOTH.
BY THE WAY, IF THERE WERE AN
ENCOURAGE-A-BONER APP YOU SHOULD
BE IN THE TESTIMONIAL PART OF
THE COMMERCIALS.
(LAUGHTER)
"I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT
ENCOURAGE-A-BONER."
LET'S SEE WHAT TV'S ANDY DALY
HAS TO SAY ABOUT
ENCOURAGE-A-BONER.
>> HEY, GUYS, IT IS TIME TO
ENCOURAGE A BONER.
(LAUGHTER)
>> AND IT'S LIKE THAT SARAH
MCLAUGHLIN DOG COMMERCIAL WHERE
HER SONG PLAYS OVER.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: JUST THESE SAD FLACCID
PENISES.
♪ IN THE ARMS OF AN ANGEL...